Speaker 1: Donald Trump issued a Christmas
message that was not heartwarming.
In fact, it was a scary meltdown in which
he is obviously terrified, terrified, terrified
of getting himself indicted.
Here is Donald Trump's post to troth essential
truth.
Speaker 2: Central.
Speaker 1: On Christmas.
And it is not exactly a message riddled with
the imagery we might expect of reindeer and
gingerbread.
I don't know what people do on Christmas exactly.
You know, I do Jewish Christmas, which is
I get Indian food or Chinese food, and that's
exactly what I did.
But it doesn't seem this is the Christmas
imagery.
Trump said, quote, Merry Christmas to everyone,
including the radical left Marxists, of which
there are almost none that are trying to destroy
our capital C country, the Federal Bureau
of Investigation that is illegally coercing
and paying social and lamestream media to
push for a mentally disabled Democrat over
the Capitol.
Be brilliant.
Capital C Clairvoyant Trump calling himself
Clairvoyant and USA Loving.
Donald J. Trump and of course, the Department
of Injustice, which appointed a special quote,
prosecutor, end quote, who, together with
his wife and family, hates, quote, Trump and
quote, more than any other person on Earth.
Love to all, Trump says in all caps.
Speaker 2: Obama Now.
Speaker 1: This is a man deathly terrified
of getting indicted now.
Later in the show, we're going to talk about
the suggestion that Trump would be best served
pleading insanity at a at a forthcoming trial,
hypothetical forthcoming trial.
And again, even if there are charges, it doesn't
mean there's going to be a trial.
This is a guy who's very, very scared.
And, of course, we all know if and when Trump
is indicted, he's going to say it's politically
biased and it's bogus and it's nonsense and
it's the radical left Marxists and all these
different things.
And why didn't they invite Obama indicted
over Obama?
Why didn't they indict George H.W.
Bush for putting his documents in a Chinese
laundry slash restaurant, which he didn't
do?
And what about Obama's sock drawer?
As he likes to say, he means drawer.
We know that what he's going to say, but we
know that he's genuinely terrified of that
indictment.
And even if he thinks that jail time, prison
time is unlikely, as I do, I think it is not
going to happen.
It's not.
Going to happen, even though Jamie Raskin
now is saying Trump will end up behind bars.
We'll talk about that tomorrow.
I don't think it's going to happen.
Trump is scared and he doesn't want to be
indicted and he is likely being advised by
lawyers based on the reports we have about
their strategizing, that he is going to get
indicted maybe by the Southern District of
New York, maybe by the DOJ federally, maybe
in Georgia, maybe in all three, maybe in two
of the three.
And he's terrified and he's coming unglued.
And that's exactly what we are seeing.
We are going to, later in the week, dig into
some of the other aspects of this.
But later on in today's show, we will talk
about insanity.
Defense is in general, which is actually a
really interesting topic.
And Lawrence Tribe's recent explanation of
why that's Trump's best bet.
We will take a quick break.
Make sure you have liked the show on Facebooks,
Zuckerberg's Facebooks at Facebook.com
slash The David Pakman Show.